good afternoon thank you thanks for
inviting me today I want to help all of
you sell your ideas the Steve Jobs way I
like to call this the new rules of
persuasive presentations because I think
to a lot of you these techniques will be
new Oh at least maybe it's a new way of
looking at an old problem
which is how do we sell our ideas
effectively as graduate students at
Stanford you all have ideas to share you
have ideas for new products new
businesses new methods new ways of doing
things ideas that are going to change
the world some people are better than
others at telling their story Steve Jobs
for example is an extraordinary
storyteller he's so exceptional in fact
I wrote an entire book on him the
presentation secrets of Steve Jobs now
this book I am proud to say has become
an international bestseller and
companies around the world companies
that recruit from Stanford or using some
of these techniques to completely
transform the way they communicate the
vision behind their companies how many
of you were here when Alan Mulally spoke
CEO Ford last week Alan called me
personally last year called me on my
cell phone I was actually in the gym at
the time on my treadmill kind of
embarrassing I'm running out thinking
why is this guy calling from Detroit and
he said this is Alan Mulally from for
just want to know I read this cover to
cover it's really helped a lot so that's
the kind of reaction I'm getting from
people but it's not just about Steve
Jobs I'm going to give you ideas from
many many other communicators who
consciously or not apply the very same
techniques when they're pitching their
companies are pitching their products
but let's begin with a premise I hope we
can all agree with a person can have the
greatest idea in the world but if that
person cannot convince enough other
people
it doesn't matter it's always matter to
Steve Jobs Steve Jobs always thinks
differently about communicating the
vision behind Apple and what can the
rest of us learned I learned quite a bit
techniques that I now offer my clients
and my clients touch your life every
single day from the computers you buy to
the electronic gadgets you use to the
foods you eat to the medical devices
that keep you healthy to the cars you
drive to the gas that goes into those
cars and the energy that keeps America
moving forward my clients are in the
news every day they improve your life
every day and they are using these
techniques and some of them here
Medtronic especially which is a big
client of mine recruits directly from
Stanford and they are using these
techniques so I hope that you are a
receptive audience I want to teach you
some of the techniques that we use with
high-level executives okay shall I go
through them the ones that apply to you
specifically the ones that you can adopt
today for your very next presentation
I'm going to start with the most
important one passion passion is
everything you cannot inspire unless
you're inspired yourself and for Steve
Jobs passion plays a very very important
role at Apple in 1997 Steve Jobs
returned to Apple after a 12-year
absence Apple was very close to
bankruptcy at the time Steve Jobs held
an informal staff meeting I'm going to
show you a clip from that meeting it's
informal and you can tell because he's
wearing shorts when he really wants to
dress up he'll wear blue jeans and
running shoes so informal staff meeting
but listen to the role passion would
play in revitalizing the Apple brand -
values this is a very complicated world
the very ones
world and we're not going to get a
chance to hit people to remember much
about us no kindness and so we have to
be really clear on what we want to know
ties our customers want to approve the
battle and what is it that we sandwich
where it is different for and what word
of that isn't Megan boxes for people to
get their jobs although we do that well
we do that better than almost anybody in
Sunday's practice about some normal
apple-pie core is core value is that we
believe that people with passion can
change the world people with passion can
change the world for the better
this man certainly believes that Richard
Tate was a client of mine about five
years ago classic American entrepreneur
sketches an idea on the back of an
airplane napkin during a cross-country
flight an idea for a board game which
everyone could excel in one area or
another some people are better at trivia
art culture music what game did he build
cranium walk into cranium headquarters
and you are hit with a wave of fun and
enthusiasm and engagement the likes of
which I've rarely seen in corporate
America but again you need to understand
that it starts from the leader it starts
from the entrepreneur whose vision it
was to build that company but what is
Richard Tate passionate about passion is
contagious by the way he is passionate
not so much about building board games
he's passionate about building
self-esteem and it comes across in every
conversation you have with him and in
every television interview especially
when he's asked a question like where
two great ideas come from these ideas
you just know when you're onto something
and just don't take no for an answer
you're just gonna keep pushing you know
resilience and perseverance those are
key captures it's an entrepreneurs they
can feel that idea and just don't take
no for an answer we have sufficiently
when we got started at first and they
said don't mean your day job so you're
crazy
everyone's having it was we're crazy so
you call it my or dad and I said so that
was going to be Microsoft's our game
company nice if you watch that tell my
friends there's a time to follow my
heart
we're gonna make history and at this day
you know I would say to anyone is is
persevere and you can feel do that year
you see if you know it yeah you've got
your friends and we're gonna fire at
your friends you know you get out with
this tester this is a good idea or not
and you know you're onto something but
it's what you said yeah I would you want
to raise a few ideas because everything
you say is a magnet for success almost
enough people don't think Oh follow your
gut go for and you just you just get you
any idea I look there's one thing which
I hear the other day and you guys are
talking about customers great these
people called rainy acts and I've never
forgotten that our customers are our
sales force we sold a million games with
no advertising all of our customers
talking about our product or service
experience we sold a million games with
no advertising our customers are our
best sales force
did you see the reaction of the host
passion is contagious
when I first worked went for Richard
Tate a colleague of mine said that
within five minutes you're going to want
to work at cranium now I didn't go to
work for cranium but I understand I
understand when I interviewed Suze Orman
who is one of the world's great
financial planners I asked her
point-blank I some what makes you such
an extraordinary communicator she said
because I've learned to appeal to
somebody's heart before their brain I
understand what you saying you need to
make emotional connections with people
you need to share what you're passionate
about she's not passionate about mutual
funds Suze Orman is passionate about
avoiding the crushing financial
that caused so much pain for her and her
family she was growing up
what does Starbucks sell what do they
sell coffee so why is it that when I
interviewed Howard Schultz for Business
Week article and a book about three
years ago he rarely mentioned the word
coffee I thought he was selling coffee
because that's not what he is selling
and he was very adamant about it they
are selling a workplace that treats
people with dignity and respect
happy customers are happy employees
equal happy customers what a formula it
works for Starbucks but he rarely
mentioned the word coffee and I said
Howard why are you talking about coffee
that's what you sell
he said well sure I like coffee but
that's not what my business stands for
so you need to ask yourselves what am i
passionate about and it's not the
obvious Howard Schultz is not passionate
about coffee Suze Orman is not selling
mutual funds Richard Tate is not selling
board games and Steve Jobs is not
selling computers he's selling tools to
help you unleash your personal
creativity there's a big difference but
that's the very first question you need
to ask yourself when you're creating the
message behind your product or company
or service what is it that I'm truly
passionate about now let's dig into real
techniques that you can use today for
your very next presentation how many of
you are on Twitter
okay my twitter handle is carmine gallo
if you'd like to follow me I'd like to
continue this conversation with you how
many characters does Twitter allow 140 I
think it's a great exercise if you
cannot explain what you do in 140
characters go back to the drawing board
it's important because your brain craves
meaning before details a neuroscientist
at the University of Washington John
medina taught me this he said carmine
when primitive man went into a tiger he
did not ask how many teeth does the
tiger have he asked Willie
eat me should I run big picture before
details this is the way your brain wants
to process information
let's halt with this slide typical slide
right this was delivered by a Morgan
Stanley analyst at a technology
conference she had about 20 minutes and
she wanted to deliver eight big ideas a
themes that's too much information
where's the big picture before the
details these actually support a broader
theme a couple of journalists who were
in the room at the time wrote about it
much more simply but they focused on the
big picture one of the headlines was the
mobile Internet is growing faster than
you've ever imagined now imagine if she
had come out to say the mobile Internet
is growing faster than you've ever
imagined and I'm going to tell you why
what's more interesting this slide which
I created in two minutes or this one big
picture before details Steve Jobs does
this all the time when he introduced the
MacBook Air this could have been a very
typical slide the average communicator
would have created a slide like this
today we are very excited to introduce a
thin lightweight notebook computer it
has a 13 inch widescreen display backlit
keyboard Intel processor what's the
problem here too much information what's
the big picture in a sentence it's the
world's thinnest notebook
oh isn't that much more interesting and
easier for you to process than all of
the details first it's the world's
thinnest notebook that's the way Steve
Jobs framed it what do you notice about
the slide simple visual and when he
delivers the headline the one thing that
he wants you to remember that's all he
has on the slide he does this all the
time in every presentation
what's the iPad the iPad is our
advanced technology in a magical and
revolutionary device that was his second
slide when he introduced the iPad
because that's all he wants you to know
right now before getting into the
details I did notice at an unbelievable
price they stopped using that this was
the only time he actually used that
maybe people started thinking to
themselves $800 that's that's not
unbelievable unbelievably high maybe but
it's interesting that was the last time
I saw it on that one slide again Apple
does this all the time a few months ago
when they introduced the Beatles on
iTunes go to the website what did you
see The Beatles now on iTunes how many
of you would have the courage at your
companies to effectively declutter your
website remove everything else except
the one thing you want people to get
across the one thing you want people to
remember again the Apple website they do
this all the time it takes courage to be
simple it takes courage to communicate
simply if you cannot communicate what
you do in 10 words or less a short
sentence or say 140 characters go back
to the drawing board once you give me
the big picture as an audience member I
need to understand the problem that
you're trying to solve
I call this introducing the antagonist
because every great story and a
presentation is a story every great
story requires a hero and a villain so
think of your presentation the same way
in 1984 when Steve Jobs first introduced
Macintosh Macintosh obviously the Mac
was the hero IBM was the villain at
least in the Steve Jobs narrative so he
actually crafted the story IBM would
play the the villain part of the role
Mac would come in to save the day IBM
was a mainframe computer at the time
mainframe computer maker just getting
into personal computers for the first
time and Steve Jobs created this this
press
Taoiseach and messaging around Apple
would be the only one to stand in in
IBM's way and make the world safe for us
creative people in the world there's a
news very dramatic stuff but he actually
crafted the narrative but more often
than not the enemy in a Steve Jobs
presentation is not a competitor or one
competitor it could be a category of
problems in need of a solution so when
Steve Jobs introduced the iPhone in 2007
he didn't just point to one villain but
a problem among all the villains in need
of a solution
watch as he outlines the problem and
offers a solution all in two minutes
why are you ready here's one smartphone
right over the cute library pom trail
nokia e62 usual suspects and what's
wrong with their user interface well the
problem with them is really sort of in
the bottom 40 there is this stuff right
here they all have these keyboards
whether they're whether you need it or
not to be there and they all have these
control buttons that are fixed in
plastic and it was the same for every
application every application wants a
slightly different user interface a
slightly optimized set of buttons just
for it and what happens if you think of
a great idea six months from now you
can't run around add a button these
things are yet so what do you do it
doesn't work because the buttons and
controls can't change they can't change
for each application and they can't
change down the road if you think of
another great idea you want to add to
describe well how you solve this hmm it
turns out we have solved it we solved it
in computers 20 years ago we solved it
with a bitmap screen because this way
anything we want put any user in your
face up and a plain device we solve it
with the mouse right we solve this
problem so how are we going to take this
to a mobile device what we're going to
do
get rid of all these buttons just make a
giant screen a giant screen now we don't
want to carry around a mouse right so
what are we going to do
Oh Silas right we're using Silas yeah
Silas gave them and put away your losing
yeah nobody want to sighs so let's not
use insights we're going to use the best
pointing device in the world we're using
my advice that we're all born with one
what's happened we'll use up favors when
it touches with our fingers and we have
invented a new technology kind of
multi-touch which is phenomenal it works
like magic you don't need a Silas it's
far more accurate than any types of clay
that's ever been shipped in over son
intent touches it's super smarts even do
multi-finger gestures on it and boy had
we had hahaha all right I'm glad it
stopped there take a view of that slide
we're going to get back to something
like that what do you notice about those
slides by the way simple visual you
notice what he did he did three things
he informed he educated and he had fun
at the same time information education
and entertainment all in two minutes I
find that quite extraordinary
very few communicators have that skill
but you need to begin by asking yourself
what problem do I solve what problem do
I solve what's the villain here and then
you can offer the solution enter the
hero the solution better sell a benefit
though what's the benefit behind it
people want to know what's in it for me
I learned this in journalism 101 I went
to UCLA went to Northwestern to study
journalism then I went to CNN and some
other media outlets after that
I'd learn this is my first day of
journalism school what's in it for me
why do I care let me show you an example
of how we sell the benefit in some of my
clients at CES this year Intel launched
a new microprocessor it's called Sandy
Bridge
that's the codename Sandy Bridge
actually is the largest biggest
technological leap in Intel's history
it's a big deal for Intel and it's a big
deal for consumers here's the technical
definition Sandy Bridge is based on the
32 nanometer manufacturing process its
processing cores feature hyper-threading
and turbo boost technology or any of you
inspired and excited about running out
today to buy one of these new computers
yeah good he gets it that's powerful
stuff though that's actually technology
that's going to improve your life
significantly but I don't see too many
hands so nobody's interested yet okay
let's try this what if you walk into a
Best Buy and somebody said something
like think of the microprocessor is the
brain of your computer now with these
Intel chips you get two brains in one
computer it's the fastest chip on the
market what does that mean to you video
games will look amazingly realistic
you'll be able to transfer video and
upload it to YouTube much more quickly
in fact what took four minutes to encode
will now take 30 seconds and finally
it's much more energy efficient that
means you'll get much longer battery
life so the next time any of you are
looking for a new computer do you think
you're going to ask for this new
generation Intel processor do you think
you want it now yes yeah more hands why
I just what I told you earlier is
exactly the same thing it was exactly
the same thing but I changed the
messaging instead of focusing on the
chip and its features what would the
features do for you
you sell the benefit introduce the hero
which is your product your service your
company but you better tell me why I
need it and how it will improve my life
what was the big question when Steve
Jobs introduced the iPad a lot of people
were skeptical they said they'd ask
themselves why do I need another device
I have a smartphone and I have a laptop
what's in it for me Steve Jobs gave us
the answer and smartphones now everyone
uses a laptop in the world lately is
there one for third category of device
in something that's between a live
active smartphone and of course we
founded this question for years as well
the bars three high in order to
literally create a new category of
devices those devices are now happily
far better at doing some key tasks
they're far better at there's some
really important things better than a
laptop better than bark on what kind of
castes well things like browsing the web
that's pretty tall order something
favorite browsing the web and laptop
okay we met in July and sharing
photographs video watching videos if you
want your music collection playing games
reading ebooks if there's going to be a
third category device it doesn't have to
be better at these kinds of tasks and a
laptop or smart oh boy there's no reason
to me now people have bought that
netbook the problem is nipples aren't
better at any
they have low quality the slice and they
don't want PC so forth so they're not
better than a laptop at anything they're
just cheaper they're just cheap laptops
and we don't think that is like [ __ ]
don't you take this person and we call
this is what it looks like right here he
always just happens to have one right
here he informs he educates and he
entertains when's the last time you
laughed at a presentation or had fun
with it that takes courage but it also
takes thought you need to answer the
question before you even open your
slides why should my audience care
because that's the only question on
their minds there don't really care
about your technology or your features
or the commission that you need to make
they don't care about any of that they
just want to know what's in it for me
why should I care answer that don't
leave them guessing now I know many of
you at least the first years unless I'm
mistaken are taking a lot of
quantitative courses that true yeah a
lot of heavy financial courses this year
let's talk about something then bringing
numbers to life Steve Jobs will rarely
introduce a data point a statistic
without putting it into some kind of
context that people can understand so
for example in 2001 when Steve Jobs
introduced the iPod for the first time
he said it had 5 gigabytes of storage 5
gigabytes of storage I mean I know what
is it today many of you may have
purchased the latest 160 gigs something
like that but it was 5 gigs in 2001 what
does that mean to anybody 5 gigabytes of
storage ok that's not that interesting
on I even sure what it means Oh
it meant 1,000 songs storage capacity
for 1,000 songs now it's more
interesting but Steve Jobs goes one step
further it's 1,000 songs in your pocket
now I'm interested now I'm inspired
Steve Jobs does this all the time
and as do all the other executives at
Apple I've seen many other presentations
as well it's very effective don't just
throw out a big number without putting
it into some kind of context that is
relatable to me in my life cisco has the
same type of challenge cisco makes big
routers and switches then nobody ever
sees so they become very good at putting
big numbers into perspective and making
a very interesting last year cisco
released a CRS 3 router capable of
handling 322 terabits per second it's a
big number isn't it not very interesting
it just sounds like a big number so when
John Chambers the CEO was giving
presentations on it in every
presentation and in every interview he
really even used the number 322 terabits
but he did say powerful enough to stream
every movie ever made in four minutes
powerful enough to download the entire
Library of Congress in one second that's
interesting that actually got picked up
by a lot of mainstream press who
otherwise would have no business
covering a Cisco router but he made it
interesting put numbers into perspective
bring numbers to life I just want to
introduce that concept for you because I
know a lot of you are taking those sort
of those classes in your first year what
have I been doing in the last few slides
I've been trying to keep them as simple
as possible and as visual as possible
when you are creating slides it helps to
think visually how many of you give
powerpoints create powerpoints how many
of you use PowerPoint everybody how many
of you use Apple Keynote okay a few of
you it's a beautiful program very
refined program all my clients use
PowerPoint 97 percent of us use
powerpoints so I tend to use PowerPoint
as well for compatibility reasons but
this goes beyond PowerPoint I've seen
really off
keynote presentations as well I so I
don't think it's so much the
presentation software as much as it is
how to tell the story using the software
I think what happens is Microsoft and
PowerPoint sort of make it easy to be
mediocre this is what it does it forces
you to create a title slide and then add
bullets and more bullets and sub bullets
until you're really in the weeds and oh
there's empty space we can't have that
so let me add some cheesy clipart and
you know I'm an MBA so I need to add it
shard in a squiggly line and there you
have it the world's ugliest slide at
least so I thought when I first created
that slide until I saw this that's a
real slide this was delivered in the
u.s. among the US military commanders
and one general actually said he
actually said this if I can understand
this slide we'll have won the war so I
thought I could make a really bad
PowerPoint when I wanted to but this
stops it there's no way I can compete
that is a bad PowerPoint slide what's
the difference what's the difference the
difference is that a slide in a Steve
Jobs presentation simply complements the
messenger it's Steve Jobs telling the
story Steve Jobs is the narrator think
of the sort of a Broadway play because
he is very theatrical Steve Jobs is the
central figure
the narrator the slides are the backdrop
that's all they do is serve to
complement the story
the average PowerPoint slide has 40
words it is difficult to find 40 words
in 10 slides in a Steve Jobs
presentations you will get words and
text and images as well there's a reason
for this whether he's doing it
consciously or not
neuroscientists will tell you there is
something called picture superiority
it simply means when information is
delivered verbally people will remember
about ten percent of the information add
a picture or an image retention goes up
to 65 percent in fact too many words on
a slide is actually very difficult for
the brain to process because according
to John Medina who I talked to the brain
interprets every letter as a picture so
what happens is the brain is literally
choking on text now some of you more
thoughtful ones of smart MBAs are
thinking in themselves well I can read
it doesn't bother me when I'm reading
yeah now try reading and have somebody
else talk to you at the same time can
you process both No
so why do we expect people to do so when
we're giving PowerPoint presentations
let's create wordy slides with a hundred
words on them and I'm going to tell you
something really complicated and I'm
going to expect you to concentrate on
either one it doesn't work
what does Steve Jobs do let me create
let me create a really ugly slide around
the MacBook Air this I think would have
been a typical slide but again after
looking at that other PowerPoint this
looks by genius those of you who are
looking at this closely can tell there's
different font sizes different sizes
shapes there's a little clip art because
god forbid we have empty space this
gives you all of the details about the
MacBook Air well when Steve Jobs and his
team we're trying to decide how do we
communicate the vision behind this
computer in a way that everybody is
going to remember and how do we do that
in a slide they came up with this it's
so thin it's fits inside one of those
envelopes why do you need any text on
that what's more interesting
what's more memorable this or that but
this takes thought say this doesn't take
a lot of thought this should just throw
a bunch of words on the slide that takes
practice thought
research ahead of time so think visually
and in order to think visually guess
what you've got to start like this
sketching brainstorming whiteboarding
before you open up the slides visual
slides help in creating what's called a
holy smokes moment this is that one
moment in a presentation that
everybody's going to remember everybody
remembers when Steve Jobs pull the
macbook air out of the envelope at least
everybody who was in the audience that
day John Medina taught me he said
carmine the brain does not pay attention
to boring things so don't make it boring
when the brain detects an emotionally
charged event anger fear surprise it
actually releases dopamine into the
system acting as a mental post-it note
saying remember this create that one
moment of surprise Steve Jobs did so
when he introduced the iPhone he could
have come out and said hey we're really
excited today to introduce this new
technology it's Apple's new smartphone
first time Apple has created a phone I
can't wait to tell you about it yeah he
could have done that most people would
have instead Steve Jobs did this hey
Morgan Jersey three rows across is less
is a widescreen iPod Touches
the serpent is a revolutionary
and the third is a breakthrough internet
communications of us
so three days a widescreen iPod with
touch controls a revolutionary old phone
and breakthrough Internet communications
plus I bought the phone in in a
communicator
these are not three separate devices one
we are calling it iPhone today
today Apple is going to reinvent the
bomb pretty entertaining isn't it
what's the Twitter finally headline from
that presentation today Apple reinvents
the phone that was on their press
release on their website and in the
presentation what's the one thing you
want me to remember when you create
visual presentations or you think about
how to move away from the slides in
order to create these emotionally
charged events it helps to think about
it this way
what's a multi-sensory experience I can
create that has absolutely nothing to do
with the slides sometimes the most
memorable parts of a presentation are
not about what's on the slide and yet we
spend 98 percent of our time getting the
fonts just right in the right images
oftentimes we're going to think about
how to connect with people beyond the
slide Bill Gates has been doing a very
good job of this Bill Gates is now the
world's largest philanthropist
and he has the challenge of talking
about global problems very complicated
problems in simple to understand
language which has been doing very very
well last year he gave a talk about
reducing childhood deaths in malaria the
most memorable part of his presentation
one that went viral had nothing to do
with his slides
although the slides were beautifully
created they were very visual lot of
images very powerful slides but the most
memorable part of his presentation was
multi-sensory it went beyond the slides
for example there's more money into
baldness drugs an occasional area now
all this is everything
and rich man our priorities have been
attacked but malaria they eat the
million deaths a year caused by malaria
greatly understand its impact or 200
million people any one time or suffering
from it means you can't get the
economies in these areas going because
they're just it hold things back so much
now letters course transmitted by
mosquitoes I brought some here so you
could turn this will let let those room
around the it's our you only for people
to have
those receivers or not mom yeah he was
going to say those mosquitoes are not
affected that is astonishing
he created a multi-sensory experience it
was a memorable experience and he got
people to laugh about a serious subject
like malaria but he made a memorable and
I know as a fact that he's always
thinking about how to communicate these
very difficult issues in a way that
people can understand now there's one
other topic I just want to introduce to
you briefly I'm not going to go into it
we can do a whole half-day workshop on
this but we're not going to today I just
want to introduce it to you because it's
important you can have all these things
you could create a wonderful PowerPoint
presentation great messaging you've got
a hero and a villain but you have to
deliver it well you have to deliver it
effectively this is called mastering
stage presence
great communicators all have great
presence this is an important statistic
65% 65% of the impression that you leave
on someone has little to do with your
message it has to do with your facial
expressions your verbal deliver your
body language there are three things
that you can do today that will help you
stand out from the vast majority of
public speakers and communicators number
one eye contact make eye contact 80 90
percent of the time that's why I don't
like it when people have too many notes
to read from or if you put too many
words on the slide
you're breaking eye contact Steve Jobs
rarely breaks eye contact he will turn
to a display bring something up and turn
back to the audience open posture open
simply means there's nothing in between
me and you if I had delivered this
presentation exactly the same way but I
had done so like this the whole time
would that have left a different
impression on you why it's the same
content because 65% of the impression I
believe you nanyue has little to do with
the contact and also hand gestures use
hand gestures I'm Italian so it's easier
for me to use hand gesture
but it's okay researchers are finding
that complex thinkers use complex
gestures a lot of people will ask me
what do I do with my hands do I keep
them in my pocket take them out be
animated be animated in voice and embody
and finally let's wrap all this together
never forget that you are selling dreams
not products because your customers do
not care about your company they don't
care about your product or your service
but they do care about themselves their
hopes their goals their dreams their
ambitions help them achieve their dreams
and you'll inspire them you'll win them
over Steve Jobs has always been in the
business of selling dreams when he first
got together with Wozniak in the spare
bedroom of his parents house in 1974
that's actually where it started
not the garage they were just playing
with electronics and Steve Jobs had a
vision he said I would love to make
computers that are easy to use for
everyday people he was always selling
dreams in 1997 remember I told you that
he returned to Apple after being away
for about 12 years
he returned to Apple in his first major
presentation the following year he
paused at the end of his presentation
and reminded people of what Apple stood
for as a brand it's a very powerful
moment Apple and
and I can't do a lot you know I think it
always has a little difference to buy
out when we should we have to
yeah about the kitchen here's what you
think you saw in movies they often
thought giant ones they want to be sent
out to desktop think differently because
there wasn't any software at the end
unfortunately you arrived at school
where they've never been on before was
an attitude I think the kind of thing
really differently when you go to Mac it
was a totally different appeal or
totally different why you can totally
report your brain and it opened up a new
world for a lot of people who thought
differently
we're buying do it in subjects of one
yeah they can leave back Kathak you
still have to think that when we buy
anything I think the people do buy them
do you think differently and they're the
creative spirit in this world there are
people that are not deserved a job done
without the change of world and they're
not the change of oil using whatever
great tools they can give and we make
tools to those kinds of people so
hopefully what you've seen here there's
beginning steps that maybe some
confidence that we do work differently
and so the people that have been buying
our products since the beginning because
a lot of times people think they're
crazy they're not crazy genius and those
are people were making sure thank you
very much
how can you not be inspired by that but
you see what he's doing is focusing on
the customer and their needs in their
hopes and their goals he's always
thinking differently about how to
communicate and articulate the vision
behind his products he's not just
selling computers and now in true Steve
Jobs fashion those of you who have seen
Steve Jobs presentations know that he
always ends with one more thing that one
thing that typically is the most
important product introduction let me
just leave you with that one more thing
today
don't let the bozos get you down there
will always be naysayers and skeptics
and people who don't believe in your
idea or believed in your dreams
don't let them to Swede you imagine what
one young man must have felt when he
heard things like we don't need you you
haven't gotten through college yet get
your feet off my desk get out of here
you stink and we're not going to buy
your product or there's no reason why
anybody would want a computer in their
home as you can guess by now Steve Jobs
heard all of these things didn't stop it
when a Disney executive whose role it
was to revitalize the Disney Stores
asked Steve Jobs for advice Steve said
dream bigger that's my advice to you
dream bigger so that's my advice for you
folks today dream bigger see genius and
your craziness believe in yourself
believe in your ideas and above all
deliver and communicate those ideas with
confidence
clarity and passion because it's those
ideas that are going to change the world
thanks for inviting me to spend your
lunch hour with you I appreciate